ابرز اليوم هو اطلاق الفصائل الفلسطينيه
وكتائب القسام تحديدا رشقه صاروخيه لاول
مره منذ اسبوعين وفي اليوم
ال1 من الحرب على تل ابيب تحديدا اللواء
فيس دويري الخبير العسكري والسراج يحكي
لنا عن دلالاتها في هذا التوقيت محمود
المسافه تقريبا من قطاع غزه تتراوح بين 80
الى 100 كيلو وصولا الى تل ابيب صحيح نعم
جلال هذا يعتمد على تعريفنا على هذه
المسافه من اين تطلق سواء من شمال قطاع
غزه الوسط او الجنوب اضافه الى منطقه ت تل
ابيب حيث يكون هنا نصف القطر حوالي 15 كم
سنشاهد هذا على الخريطه التفاعليه كيف ان
هذه المسافات تختلف لكننا نتحدث عن حد
ادنى 65 كم وحوالي 100 كم اذا اطلقت من
اقصى شمال غزه باتجاه تل ابيب نتحدث عن
حوالي 60 كم كما نشاهد هنا ا من منطقه
الوسط نتحدث عن حوالي خ 75 كم من جنوب اي
قطاع غزه نتحدث عن حوالي 90 م تقريبا اذا
هذه هي المديات هذا هو علامه فارقه هذا
ليس هذا ليس فقط بسبب ليس فقط بسبب
امكانيه اطلاق الصواريخ كنا نشاهد هذا في
بدايه الحرب على غزه لكن اذا ما وصلنا هذا
الموضوع باللون الاصفر الذي نشاهده هنا
هذه هي مناطق المناورات العسكريه البريه
الاسرائيليه بمعنى ان القوات البريه تدخل
الى هنا في هذه المناطق عاده ما ما تقوم
بعمليه التوغل والانسحاب من الشرق الى
الغرب وهو ايضا يحدث في في خان يونس لكن
عمليات البريه هذه في احد اهدافها تهدف
الى تدمير الانفاق تدمير البنيه بنيه
اطلاق الصواريخ وهنا اللاف في الموضوع ان
ان هذا اللون الاصفر اصبح يغطي بشكل كبير
معظم قطاع غزه خاصه في الجهه الجنوبيه حيث
مركز وثقل العمليات البريه لكن الصواريخ
ما تزال مستمر مستمره في الانطلاق من كامل
ارجاء القطاع وهذا امر لافت في اليوم ال
15م بعد المئه هذا يقودنا الى عمليتين
رئيسيتين هنا في الشمال اضافه الى الجنوب
في
الشمال سنشاهد هنا قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كانت تقوم بعمليات بغارات
الطيران هنا على
اي الشيخ رضوان اضافه الى الرمال الجنوبي
ايضا يبدو ان هناك بعض المصادر تشير الى
مناورات دخلت فيها القوات البريه من قرب
تل الهواب باتجاه مستشفى الشفاء اضافه من
الشمال الى القرب مئات الامتار من مستشفى
الشفاء وبالتالي نشاهد عمليات بريه اخرى
جديده تحاول تطويق عمليه فك الكماشه التي
كانت في بدايات الم المراحل الاولى في
الحرب على القطاع اذا ما اتجهنا الى جنوبا
هنا الى خان
يونس خان يونس ما تزال العمليات مستمره في
هنا خاصه مع الثقل العسكري في كل من الغرب
والجنوب لكن المقاومه قالت انها كانت
تتصدى واظهرت صورا في هذه المنطقه تشير
الى انها استهدفت مجموعه من الاليات
وشاهدنا هذه الصور طبعا لا يمكن تحديد اي
منطقه تحديدا في خان يونس لكن شاهدنا
استهدافات بقذائف الياسين
ودبابات الميركافا الان نحن في عمليه كما
شاهدنا وجود اطلاق الصواريخ مناورات
عسكريه مستمره الجانب الاسرائيلي كان
يتحدث عن كشفه انفاقا في خان يونس كما قال
المتحدث العسكري الاسرائيلي قبل قليل
ويتزامن ذلك مع انسحابات اسرائيليه في
الجنوب كانت تع عمل سبع الويه في الجنوب
لكن انخفض عدد الالويه الى خمسه بعد سحب
اللواء الخ مظليين وكريات المدرع كل هذه
الصوره سنعود اليما جلال ولواء فايز لنرى
التحليل العسكري كيف يسير في ظل هذه
العمليات وابدا مع اللواء دويري من اطلاق
الصواريخ بمعزل عن مكان اطلاق الصواريخ
والدفعه الصاروخيه باتجاه تل ابيب اللواء
الدويري ما الرساله العسكريه والسياسيه من
اطلاق 15 صاروخا الى تل ابيب بعد 115 يوما
من الحرب يعني الان الرساله السياسيه تعلو
على الرساله العسكريه كما
اقراها الان بعد 115 يوم بعد التصريحات
اليوميه القضاء على حماس تقليم اظافر حماس
الى غير ذلك تقوم حماس في اليوم ال 115
وتطلق صواريخ تعتبر متوسطه المدى بالنسبه
لصواريخ القسام وليس بالنسبه ستاندرد
العالمي ام طال منطقه تل ابيب
الكبرى وبالتالي كانها ترسل رساله وتقول
انت تتحدث عن القضاء على حماس تقليم اظافر
حماس القضاء على قوات القسام وبقيه
الفصائل لا نحن ندير معركتنا البريه بنجاه
وقدمنا لك في هذا اليوم فيديو وندير
معركتنا على المستوى السياسي والاستراتيجي
بن جاعه ارسلنا لك الصواريخ الى تلي ابيب
اذا نحن دير معركتنا الارضيه بمهنيه
واحتراف ونوقع باكل خسائر وفاتوره التكليف
فاتوره التكاليف باهظه وفي البعد السياسي
والاستراتيجي انا ارسل لك الصواريخ وهي
رساله موجهه لك موجهه ل المجتمع الكيان
الاسرائيلي موجهه الى الجانب الامريكي
والى حتى الفرقاء الذين يقومون بدور
الوساطه كانها تقول لهم انا لا ازال متمكن
اي من من الارض ولا ازال قادر على
الاستمرار في القتال
وارباك دوله الاحتلال نشير لنا نتابع
الصور هذا بقايا الصاروخ او ما حتى حسب ما
قال محمود قبل قليل بانه محرك الصاروخ سقط
على هذه السياره وتسبب باضرار ماديه بحسب
المعلومات 15 صاروخا اطلق من قطاع غزه تم
اعتراض 12 صاروخ كيف يتم كيف تعترض ال قبه
الحديديه الص
الان اليه عمل القبه الحديديه تتكون من
ثلاث اجزاء شبكه الرادار تمرير المعلومه
واعطاء الاوامر اطلاق
الصواريخ اليه عملها
تحدد الفاينال ستشن نقطه النهايه للصاروخ
المقاومه اذا كان سيسقط في ارض خاليه لا
يوجد اهداف حقيقيه لا يتم اعتراضه متى يتم
اعتراضه اذا كانت النهايه ستقع على بشكل
خطرا الان
تم اعتراض 12 صاروخ السؤال هل الثلاثه
كانوا لاهداف ضمي ام اصابوا لم تاتي
معلومه انه ان هناك اصابات باستثناء هذا
هذه اللقطه الان اليه عمل القبه الحديديه
هي غير مصممه لتكون الراس بالراس يعني لا
يتم ارتطام مباشر لا لا هو ياتي موازيا له
لما بينفجر اذا كانت نقطه الانفجار بعيده
عن الراس ل المتفجر لصواريخ القسام يتدمر
الصاروخ وينزل الراس المتفجر وهنا قد يسبب
مشكله لهذا السبب بعض
الخبراء تحدثوا بصراحه اذا لم يكن هناك
اصابه مباشره للراس المتفجر فانت لا تعتبر
انك اسقطت الصاروخ لانه قد يحدث اضرارا
لاحقه درجه كفائتها عاده حسب الظروف انما
ت ما بين 60 الى 70% بعض المغالين تحدث عن
10% ولم اتفق معهم وبعض الداعمين حدثوا عن
90 و 95% ولا اتفق معهم طيب تتحول ال
الخريطه لواء دويري ولفتني خلال قراءه
محمود على الخارطه خاصه بالمنطقه الجنوبيه
بخانيونس
بان مناطق نشاط الجيش الاسرائيلي تتسع في
هذه النقاط ودائما نقول بانها ليست مناطق
سيطره وانما هي مناطق ن اشتباكات اشتباكات
نلاحظ بانها تتسع هذا اللون الاصفر اي
مكان تواجد ونشاط الجيش الاسرائيلي بانها
تتسع بماذا يخبركم هذا في خ يعني الان هذا
يعيدنا الى بدايات الحرب على غزه واللي مر
عليها اكثر من شهرين الخطه الاولى كانت هي
خطه مزدوجه هجوم جبوي على طول الواجهه
الشرقيه من طريق كو سفيم حتى جنوب خزاعه
وحركه التفاف من كوس فيم على القراره على
المطاحن على مدينه حمد وصولا الى واصي
والى جوش قطيف الان الجهد الرئيسي تعثر
الجهد الرئيسي تعثر تثر دخل في شمال عبسان
الجديده بين عبسان الجديده وزنه ولكنه لم
يستطع ان يتثبت واجبر على التراجع دخل من
جنوب عبسان الكبيره ومن جنوب خزاعه بين
خزاعه والفخار واجبر على التراجع الان
اعاد صياغه المقاربه العسكريه لانه ظهرت
القراره وزنه على ان انها نقاط مزعجه
فاعاد اكثر من لوائين وقاتلت لمده اسبوع
ثم انسحبت الى كسفي بعد ذلك اعاد تطوير
قوته واعاد الضغط من الجبهه الشرقيه
وا اخفق في منطقه خزاعه فانسحب اللواء الى
خارج السياج بعد ذلك تم تعزيز الجهد
الثانوي هذا كان جهد رئيسي الجهد الثانوي
كان لوائين والجهد الرئيسي كان سته الويه
الان دعم الجهد الثانوي لماذا لانه يعتبر
امكانيه تحقيق انتصار في منطقه غرب من
مدينه الحمد باتجاه المواصي اكثر سهوله
وخاصه بعد ان قام بتدمير معظم المباني في
منطقه القراره دفع بلواء ثالث دفعه من
القراره مع طريق صلاح الدين هذا الان احدث
نوع من تغيير في اداره المعركه فبالتالي
اصبحت مدينه الانوس تهاجم من الشمال
وتهاجم من كافه القطاع سواء الشمال الغربي
الغرب الجنوب الغربي والجنوب دفع بقوه
اضافيه من جنوب الفخاري ووصلت قيزان
النجار وعملت تماس مع منطقه البوليتكنيك
فاصبحت الان القوات الجيش الاحتلال تحيط
بمدينه غزه كانها نع خ عفوا بمدينه خان
يونس ب 270 درجه من اصل 360 درجه
الان لا توجد معلومات يقينيه عن مدى
التدخل وانها معركه متحركه تتقدم وتنس لكن
معظم الثقل ياتي من منطقه اين هي شارع
الرشيد من تلك المنطقه منطقه المخيم
وبالتالي المعارك ضاريه وانا سمتها معارك
كسر العظم لماذا لانه القناعه لد جيش
الاحتلال ان الاهداف التي يبحث عنها
موجوده في المنطقه طيب نقطه هنا هذا
الاصبع هنا الاصفر باتجاه الدبابه تماما
يبدو بانه يتقدم هل يبدو لك بانها محاوله
لفصل المنطقه الغربيه عن المطقه الشرقيه
يحاول الدخول مع طريق صلاح الدين على ان
تلتقي القوات القادمه من الشمال مع القوات
القادمه يعني بالتالي يتم فصل الشرق عن
الغرب هذا الخط الاسفر لا يعني تواجد
للقوات فيه لكن هذا هو الكوريدور الذي
استخدمته القوات في القتال فالقوات الان
ليست موجوده في الفخاري هي موجوده عند
البوليتكنيك انما هذا هو المقترب الذي
سلكته القوات
والان هي تتموضع في نقاط محدده في الشمال
وتحاول التقدم مع شارع صلاح الدين عند
مدينه الحمد وتحاول التقدم اتجاه المصانع
ومن الغرب باتجاه والجنوب باتجاه المخيم
في حال حدث هذا الفصل بين الغرب والشرق
لمنطقه خانيونس ما الذي قد يعنيه بالنسبه
الطفي لا هي هي الان هي نفس المعركه الان
تتسع الواجهه الدفاعيه الان طبعا التنظيم
الدفاعي هو بيعتمد على بكث الانفاق تعتبر
الاكثر تعقيدا خاصه في المنطقه الشرقيه
والتي افشلت الهجوم الان هي عمليه كما
قلنا عمليه كسر عظم من يصبر اكثرا اكثر من
يتحمل فاتوره التكاليف اكثر هو الذي سيكسب
في هذه الجوله اشر محمود قبل قليل
الانسحابات
للالوف الجنوب هل يدل على شيء نعم هناك
انسحابات هي لا نستطيع ان نجزم ما هو
السبب الحقيقي خمسه من اصل خبعه كانوا
سبعه اصبحوا خمسه الان كانوا ثمانيه سحب
لواء و وتم سحب لوائين تم سحب ثلاثه الويه
ابقي على الويه مدرعه لوائين مدرعات ولواء
مظليين ولواء جفعاتي الان لماذا تسحب هذه
الوحدات تسحب انا هناك
احتمالات وجميعها مرتبطه ببعضها البعض
اولا هذه الوحدات انهكت وبالتالي مر عليها
اشهر من القتال تلقت ضربات مؤلمه كما حدث
مع لواء جولاني عندما سحب فبالتالي يسحب
من اجل اراحه الجنود واعاده تاهيل هذه
القوه الامر الثاني ان الان حجم التفكير
الان كما اقراه هم الان اصبحوا في عزوف عن
المنطقه بن سهيلا غير قادرين على الدخول
في عبسان وبنسه هيلا فبالتالي لماذا يبقى
يزج في القوات في هذه المنطقه وهي لا تحقق
نتائج دعني اذهب الى منطقه خان يونس الان
دفع بلواء ثالث الى منطقه خان يونس فصار
لواء من الشمال ولواء من الغرب والجنوب
الغربي وهذه القوه كافيه لا بل اكثر من
كافيه لخوض هذه المعركه الان هذه القوات
التي سحبت هل ستعيد بناء القوه وتبقى في
منطقه الغلاف ام سترسل الى الحدود
الشماليه لفلسطين المحتله مع جنوب لبنان
لانه هناك تصريحات واضحه وصريحه حتى لو لو
توقف ق حزب الله عن القصف ولم ينسحب الى
شمال الليطاني قد نضطر الى القيام بعمليه
عسكريه خاصه بعد تسارع الاحداث وما جرى
يوم امس و قبلها اذا هناك احتمالات هل هو
اعاده البناء القوه وابقائها في هذه
المنطقه كح احتياط عمليات واستراتيجي ام
ترسل الى الشمال واتوقع ان الكفه كفه
الترجيح ت تميل الى وجهه نظر ان تتحرك الى
الشمال لواد بيري الناطق العسكري تحدث عن
تحقيق اهداف
واعتقال اكثر من
300 شخص سماهم مخربين ارهابيين ويقومون
بالتحقيق معهم انتشرت صور وهي ليست الاولى
انتشرت صور كثيره لمعامله جنود الاحتلال
لهؤلاء الاسرى او المعتقلين في داخل قطاع
غزه بعضهم دون ملابس بعضهم بالبسه بيضاء
بالمفهوم العسكري وباقت طاب لو سمحت كيف
ترى هذه الصوره وهذه الممارسات هذا الجيش
فاقد للاخلاق هذا جيش لا اخلاقي شاهدنا في
عمليات التسليم في الهدنه شعور المختطفين
والمحتجزين كيف كان
يودعوا
لحاجز شاهدناها بالمقابل هذا الجيش بدون
اخلاق هذا الجيش يتقن الاجرام وبدون اخلاق
فيعامل لكن السؤال هل عرض لنا صوره مقاتل
واحد
اتحداه هو مدنيين يقوم بتجريده من الملابس
ليس اكثر وبالتالي هذه شيمه ملا شيمه له
شكرا لك اللواء في زويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي التغطيه مستمره نعود اليك
خديجه للمتابعه شكرا